[Music]
when the breath of the wild - trailer
dropped Zelda fans worldwide were
stunned and left in awe at the wonder of
exactly what was happening on the screen
aside from the obvious references to
malice and Ganondorf something about the
trailer be at the cavern music
atmosphere or all of it made me feel
like an ominous horrifying act was about
to happen most fans felt this way as
well as we've all been spending the past
few months speculating on what Ganondorf
is going to do when he revives as it
appears he's in the middle of doing in
the trailer three months have passed
since we all first laid eyes on the
reveal trailer and I'm only just now
able to pinpoint exactly what about this
trailer feels so monstrously dangerous
to me you see I'm not really afraid of
what Ganondorf will do to high rule I'm
not afraid of what the green glowing
hand is doing to link if anything it
looks like it's saving him know what I'm
most afraid of what makes me feel like
this game is going to be the darkest
dissol to title yet is what Ganondorf
may do to Zelda
looking closely at the events of the
trailer we can see Lincoln Zelda
searching what appears to be an ancient
cavern in hopes of finding something
after all why else would a heroic duo
delft farther and farther into something
this cavernous unless they had a
specific reason to be there with Zelda
being known across the franchise for
having visions and being able to hear
spiritual voices that guide her and
given that she has a drive for research
and exploration as we see in breath the
wild it can be argued that Zelda is the
one searching this cavern while link her
knight follows close behind she's even
seen as the one holding a torch for the
both of them in one scene implying
leadership in their ventures when Zelda
and the Knights see something in the
distance things begin to go awry and the
trailer begins cutting quickly between
scenes in an effort to confuse the
viewers I began to feel alarmed when I
realized what happens to Zelda in this
whole encounter here we can see what is
presumably the duo's entrance to
Ganondorf holding
chamber note that link is holding a
torch here with zelda holding nothing
the next time we see Zelda she's falling
due to the ground under her feet giving
way but the scene right after shows her
standing calmly next to the Ganondorf
body holding a torch obviously this
isn't shown to us in proper
chronological order otherwise Elda
wouldn't have a torch when she's down by
Ganondorf to me it appears Zelda goes to
ganondorf's body first then retreats
when the body starts twitching to life
the D will make it back to the elevated
ground near the exit but Zelda falls
back down to the level Ganondorf is on
the last thing we see happen is Elda is
how she turns around with a shocked
horrified face on for what she's looking
at while it could be argued that the
scenes shown of Link's gloved right hand
helping Zelda up means that Link pulls
out out of danger unfortunately I don't
think we're that lucky link must have
given Zelda this helping hand before any
of these events took place when they
were climbing elsewhere and here's why
when they enter the chamber link has
both gloves on but when the hand magic
event takes place his glove is removed
if the hand magic link wields in the
trailer happens at any point when the
duo is seeing Ganondorf body as it is
very heavily implied due to the hand
being present on ganondorf's body then
he can't gives out a helping hand out of
where she's fallen because at any point
afterwards he shouldn't have his right
glove on obviously it is possible that I
could be interpreting it wrongly but if
this is true and Zelda is left down here
with a reawakening Ganondorf and no way
back up to safety I think it's probable
that Ganondorf or the malice pouring out
of him or both will possess Princess
Zelda let me explain a couple reasons
why now while this is all going to be
just speculation
there are a few reasons to believe this
may not be such a far-fetched idea
firstly it's already been explained to
us that this particular Zelda game is
going to be darker than majora's mask
this is straight from the mouth of o
pneuma himself in an IGN interview
now think about that for a second if he
really means that then exactly how dark
is he saying this game is going to be
majora's mask was arguably one of the
darkest games ever created centering
strongly around feelings of grief and
even the depressing topping of
everyone's inevitable death how could
you possibly go darker than this
well corrupting what was once a
beautiful picture of pure spirit and
righteous indignation would be a great
start secondly this has already been
done before in the game Twilight
Princess the first phase of defeating
the Demon Lord Ganondorf is a fight with
puppets Elda or in other words possessed
Zelda Ganondorf is no stranger to dirty
tactics and with the malice driven
calamity Ganon we see in breath of the
wild unless he suddenly grew a
personality I doubt he would feel very
badly about possessing her again thirdly
and most importantly Zelda herself
mentions that Ganon has an obsessive
refusal to give up on revival in the
original Japanese text this is important
because ganondorf's body looks like it
has seen better days and instead of
using this mostly dead hull of a body
why not revive again using Zelda's body
here's the real kicker
what if again and possessed Zelda still
has her powers I mean Ganon stole the
powers of the sheikah and their
technology and breadth of the wild and
was defeated I think the next step could
be to steal the power of heylia herself
if this is true if zelda is going to be
possessed and be the next incarnation of
Ganon then we do truly have a dark dark
Zelda game to look forward to but of
course as I said before this is all
speculation what do you think let me
know in the comments below I know this
was a shorter video but we really don't
have too much to go on at this point so
at this point I think this is all that
can be said about the subject thank you
so very much for watching please be sure
to leave a like if you enjoyed the
content and subscribe if you haven't
already for much much more as always a
huge huge thank you to my patreon
supporters if you're interested in
getting your name on this list at the
end of my videos
visit the patreon link in the
description below also in the
description is the link for joining our
growing discord server where you can be
in on all the funds that's all I've got
for you today
so without further ado this is mask and
henna bandits signing out
[Music]